well thank you Brad late today the
Attorney General's personal lawyer told
Fox News the Jeff Sessions is not under
criminal investigation for lying to
Congress about his rush of contacts
adding the office of special counsel
told him quote after interviewing the
Attorney General and conducting
additional investigation the Attorney
General is not under investigation for
false statements or perjury in his
confirmation hearing testimony and
related written submissions to Congress
earlier today ABC News reported that
former FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
oversaw a criminal probe obsessions who
signed off on McCabe's termination two
days before his retirement the current
FBI director Christopher Rea told NBC
News the firing was for cause and not
politically motivated I'm committed to
doing things objectively and
independently and by the book I think
that has to extend not just to our
investigations our intelligence analysis
but also has to extend the personnel
decisions and disciplinary decisions on
Capitol Hill today Republicans and
Democrats warned the 28 midterm
elections are in Russia's crosshairs
what I learned yesterday was was
horrifying
after reading the Senate intelligence
committees draft findings on Russia's
election meddling Senator King predicted
the next round will be worse they
weren't doing it for fun in 2016 what it
looks like is a test and it was
incredibly as I say thorough and and
comprehensive though no ballots were
changed the current and former heads of
Homeland Security warned against
minimizing the election threat
were there any votes that were affected
by this intrusion into any system in
America not to my knowledge sir
secretary Neilson we have no evidence
that any votes were changed once these
vulnerabilities have been made clear
it's not just Russia that we have to
worry about the Senate panel heard the
vulnerabilities include compromising
voter registration databases
manipulating NGO tallies as well as
hacking websites to publish false
results 18 months after the federal
election one senator who advocates for
paper ballots and mandatory audits says
security vulnerabilities remain does
your agent
they have the authority to mandate basic
cybersecurity in the electronic voting
machines used in this country no sir
does any agency not to my knowledge not
the federal level the witness is
considered whether a foreign power has
the ability to target swing precincts
altering voter registration data - so
confusion and undermine confidence the
result is that on Election Day we start
getting reports about thousands of
voters in different parts of the country
who can't vote because when they show up
they're not registered that sounds like
something from a novel or a drama a
dramatic presentation and the movies how
far-fetched is this I think your
hypotheticals are very good with it I
think all Americans should be concerned
about it the Homeland Security Secretary
also testified that there is no higher
government infrastructure priority than
securing the voting system Bret